What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers...
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite...
and start getting Re-al.
This is...
The Champions.
I'm De Jong!
But I'm De Youngest!
You’ve got to fight-
For your right-
To Thoooomassss!
Let me talk! Let me talk!
OK...talk.
Kevin.
The Special One is back, haha!
Hope the Premier League is ready for more...
...inho!
C’mon, Neymar. We're watching!
Oh, hey, movie night? Dope!
Is this, like, an artsy French film or something?
Uh. It’s match film.
Oh, nice. I love football movies!
Check this one out.
What the hell?
Ever since the Barca transfer fell through,
I've been sensing some weird vibes from my PSG teammates.
And honestly, I don’t get it.
I’m scoring sick goals, I got mad tekkers,
and I’ve got over a 100 million IG followers.
Like, what else do I gotta do to be liked?!
It's ridiculous, man.
You're so dope.
How could anyone not like you?
Surprise!
Zut alors!
What the hell?!
I wanted to throw you all a surprise party, you know,
to show how much I don’t hate playing with y'all in France.
We can't party. We have a match tomorrow.
OK, never stopped me before.
It took my people all day to set up that party.
I mean, I perpetuated every French stereotype I could think of...
all for nothing.
Ridiculous!
I worked an hour on that.
I used all my printer ink on that picture of Jean-Paul Belmondo.
Maybe we should have gone with the farming theme.
Neymar, we know you don’t want to be here.
That’s ridiculous, man.
You guys are like brothers to me, and believe me, I really love my siblings.
OK, then why did you offer to pay €20 million
to cover the transfer fees to Barcelona?
Uh...to save you guys money!
Pffft! Wow. You guys are, like, really ungrateful.
Are you being serious?
Have you even thanked me once
for taking all of the penalties for you over the past two years?
I want to take the penalties!
See, this is the thing, you are only worried about what Neymar wants.
You don’t care about the team.
Oh yeah? I love Paris Saint-Germany.
In fact, I love PSG so much,
that I got a giant PSG tattoo on my back!
You got a giant PSG tattoo on your back?
Yeah, bro!
Can we see it?
Uh…well, I mean, it’s like brand-new, so,
you know the doctor said it might get infected, so...
you know, I gotta keep it covered, but, uh...
Show us this tattoo, Neymar.
OK! Fine. You guys want to see it?
No problemo. I just need to...um...
just need to, uh, get this shirt off,
because it could be...it’s a bit complicated.
Show us the tattoo! Just show us the tattoo!
OK, OK! Fine, fine! Chill, Cavani.
OK, ready. Um...check this out.
What the hell is that?
This is a new low, Neymar.
OK. You know what. You guys are meaner than the PSG ultras, man!
I'm leaving! You don't deserve me!
I thought that tattoo was pretty dope.
Yeah, that artwork was sick.
I love my GPS, man.
That's how I know where I am.
Ugh. Everyone on PSG is, like, so judgmental.
I need to go somewhere where I can clear my head.
Yeah, we should go somewhere you can clear your head.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, like Ibiza!
I just don't get it.
What happened to the days when all people cared about
was flair and cool moves?
I care about your flair.
I love your tekkers.
Yeah!
It feels like all anyone cares about these days is, like...
dedication and loyalty and, like, sacrifice...you know.
That corny s--t.
Times are changing, man.
I’m just here for the money.
Hey, man. Are you OK?
Oh, great. Here comes the new guy.
I just want you to know that I don’t think you are a jerk.
You don't?
I think that you are just following your heart. Trying to be happy.
I walked the same path as you. I lost many friends.
You did?
When I was a young player in Sampdoria,
I met this beautiful woman.
A mother of three.
She was smart, sassy...but she was also sad.
You see, her husband was always away, doing...
who knows what.
Well, long story short, I fell in love with her and made her my wife.
And I even got her children's names tattooed on my arm.
That’s beautiful. And people think you’re a jerk for this?
People are set in their ways. Just look out for you.
Be really good at football,
and people will either forgive you or, if not, they will transfer you.
Thank you, Mauro.
I think this is the beginning of a beautiful friendship.
I would like that. Tell me about your family.
Well, I'm very close to them. In fact, my dad is my agent.
Oh, no way?! My wife is my agent! Do you have a wife?
Oh no, actually, but I have a beautiful sister whom I'm very close with.
Really? I would love to meet her.
Maybe we can all take a yacht trip together someday?
Yo! That would be dope!
So dope!
I love yachts, man!
Maybe he'll get a tattoo of us some day.
Check out "Your Call"
BR Football's new interactive adventure that's
so realistic you can even...
fight your teammate in training.
Pfft! Like that would ever happen.